talk to us about approximate
implications and applications in pgm
thank you
thank you for the invitation
um
okay so i will start with some
background uh before i talk about
approximate implication i will talk
about its exact counterpart which i'm
sure many of you are familiar with and
it's applications
in
importantly in artificial intelligence
in the relational databases and i will
then describe the approximate
implication problem and our results uh
some of our results on this
this is largely a joint work with dan
suchu
and then in the time i have left i will
briefly discuss in the application of
some of these ideas in a problem that
basically comes from relational
databases but has many parallels also
for probabilistic graphical models
and in particular for a learning
structure of the graphical models to
have a lot to do with it okay so i'll
start so i don't have to say a lot about
conditional independences we know that
this is important in
graphical modeling basically conditional
independence relations are precisely
what enables this low dimensional
representation of complex distributions
and allows for efficient inference in
learning in this stock we will
characterize as known that we would say
if x y and z are three disjoint sets of
random variables then we can say that x
and y are conditionally independent
given z if the associated mutual a
conditional mutual information
is zero
um so i want to say that conditional
independence actually has an important
part also in
in data management in
specifically when you define schemas for
relations so i will very
i will not be very technical about this
but i think you will get the idea i will
try to show this by an example
so here we have a very simple example of
a relation a relation has attributes and
values the couples in the relation
and the way
you in data management we define certain
integrity constraints which are kind of
rules uh in the which are sentences in
first order logic which basically define
when the content of the relation is
consistent okay so what this rule says
and the syntax is really not important
is basically that we can partition or
decompose this relation into two sub
relations
okay as you see here where the
intersection between them in terms of
the attributes is the set a d
okay so these are the two projections of
this relation on the subset of
attributes a c d f
and a b d e notice that a d is common to
both
and we are going to say that the
relation abides to this rule
okay always consistent with this all if
when we take the join of these two
relations we get the original relation
back so in the sense it is like this
lossless type of decomposition and this
is very important
this is really a fundamental property in
relation to databases it allows us to
enforce data integrity correctness and
consistency
and
one of the important things that it does
it allows us to minimize redundancy it
is in a sense it can make the a data we
can represent the data a
in a much smaller space so it is also
can be a form of compression
okay so what is the relation between the
two
um and basically why does this define a
conditional independence for relational
databases so we can define the empirical
distribution
of
a relation as the uniform distribution
over the topic so for example here this
is what we see and basically if this
rule holds then it will not be
surprising uh to know that basically
that we have this conditional
independence that holds in the empirical
distribution basically that
in this case b and c are independent
given a and this really can be is a
maybe it is a quite
intuitive and indeed in 1987 it was
shown that if we fix
a relation and its empirical
distribution then a functional
dependency
meaning a for example here a
functionality determines b if and only
if the conditional entropy
b given a in this same empirical
distribution is 0 and this multi-value
dependency this ability to decompose the
relation into two parts holds if and
only if the conditional mutual
information is zero so here we have
basically a kind of conditional
independence for relational databases
so what is the implication problem so we
start out with a a a set of conditional
independence relation we're going to
call it big sigma and we have another
conditional independence that we call
tau
and we're going to say that sigma
implies style if for any joint
probability distribution p
if each one of the conditional
independence relations in sigma holds in
p then tau holds in p as well
okay and this problem
was studied both in the ai and the
database communities um in the community
the work by geiger and pell and in the
database community slightly earlier
in the late 70s and 80s
okay so
and so this seems like a this
really theoretical problem but it is
actually something that we encounter all
the time because actually for example
this separation is a form of implication
right basically how so here we have like
destroy a a
distribution
and we know that we
construct the bayesian network using
what is called the recursive basis right
this basically says that for every
random variable it is independent of
some of its non-descendants some of
those that appear before it
given some subsets so for example here
we see an example of the recursive basis
and the d separation allows us to derive
additional conditional independences for
example this separation here would tell
us that given x2 x1 is independent of x3
and x4 this was not in the original
recursive basis but it is derived from
this and the known theorem states that
this process of this separation is both
a sound and complete system for
inferring conditional independences from
this recursive basis so we see that
basically this separation is a form of
exact implication
okay so before i go on i will just uh
define some notation so we in what
follows we consider a joint probability
distribution p
over and random variables uh all of
these sets of the random variables we
assume that they are disjoint we are
going to say that a conditional
independent statement is saturated if
the union of this set is the entire set
of random variables and it is marginal
if z is the empty set
a functional dependency is simply a
special type of conditional independence
okay so
and it can be seen like this that
conditional entropy is zero if and only
if this mutual information
why why given x is zero okay
so what is known about the exact
implication problem so we know that
there's a polynomial time sound and
complete decision procedure that is
based on the semi graphite axioms under
the following conditions when sigma is a
set of saturated conditional
independences a set of marginal
conditional independences and tau is
marginal
when sigma is the recursive basis of a
bayesian network
and i will mention that there's always
an extension of this when it is the
recursive basis and the set of
functional dependencies and there may be
the a lesson that is known as when sigma
has carbonylity two meaning it contains
exactly two conditional independent
statements
on the other hand there is also a
negative result it is known that the
in general there is no finite
axiomatization meaning in the general
case when no assumptions are made on
sigma there does not exist any finite
set of axioms
for that can derive all of the
conditional independent statements that
hold in a distribution
okay so uh
and this is also a well known
okay so now that we basically have
understood what the exact implication is
i would describe approximate implication
and the some of the motivation
so basically all of the system what i
showed you up until now this this
separation and everything that is done
is basically it assumes that the
conditional independence is holding the
exact sense mainly if the
associated mutual information measures
are zero then we can derive this
additional
conditional independences
okay
however most structural learning
algorithms actually derive these
conditional dependencies from data and
we cannot really expect them to hold
exactly we can think about them maybe
this conditional
mutual information is not very big it
might be up to some threshold epsilon
but we cannot always assume that it is
zero
and this raises the following question
what happens when we drop this
assumption
that the set of conditional
independences in sigma hold exactly
exactly zero and basically what
guarantee can we provide on the
consequent in such a case
okay
so i will now describe the approximate
implication problem and some of
our results okay so we've seen the
definition of exact implication and so
we are now going to define approximate
implications so we're going to say that
sigma approximately implies tau if for
any joint probability distribution p the
associated conditional mutual
information is bounded by a linear
combination
of the mutual information values in
sigma
meaning we have some
lambda some positive lambda
such that the associated information
theoretic measure associated with tau is
at most lambda times the sum
of a conditional independence measures
in sigma
okay and we want this just like for the
exact case we want this to hold for any
joint probability distribution
and basically the question the first
question we are asking is if we have
exact implication is it necessarily the
case that we have approximate
implication
okay
mainly if the conditional independence
is in sigma almost hold can we say the
tau also almost holds
and for this we would need to prove an
inequality this one
and if the answer is positive basically
we can we we have this notion of safety
then we can say that if if the answer is
positive then the
current systems that we have in place
for inferring conditional independence
can be used for inferring approximate
conditional independence
so note that this is actually not quite
enough because this lambda here can be
very big we want to be able to bound
islam right if it is very big then
basically we did not do too much so
what we need to do we need to prove a
bounded inequality we want to prove an
inequality where lambda is
quite is not very big
and then this raises yes i'm sorry i
just wanted to clarify so in the
definition of approximate implication
was there are assumptions on lambda
no so in the approximation we just say
there is this uh feat that there's the
uh affinity lambda but uh what i'm
saying what will what i'm saying here is
that
for in for practical purposes we want
lambda not to be very big we want to be
able to prove this say
okay so this is what we want to show and
then basically we
we would say that we need to make some
assumptions here
under what conditions
can this bounded inequality hold under
what conditions to
sigma and underwater conditions to tau
notice that the other direction is
immediate right because
if h of sigma is zero then h of tau is a
atmosphere and it is always positive so
in a sense we can also say that
approximate implication is in fact a
generalization of the exact counterpart
okay so it might seem intuitive that
this would hold but actually this is not
the case at all so
in 2013 in this paper by casa de
nomoscenco
they showed the following exact
implication it is a very simple exact
implication over even just four random
variables so this exact implication
holds
however
for any lambda
we can devise a probability distribution
in which this inequality holds
so we see that that approximate
implication does not necessarily hold
even for these simple
a distributions
okay so this is not something that we
can hope to save for
in the general case
okay so what are the results that we
have and indeed as i showed we need to
make some assumptions on sigma intel in
order to be able to say something about
this
so the results we have are as follows so
if sigma is a set of
saturated conditional independencies and
functional dependencies and tau is a
function of dependency then we have this
inequality basically with a lambda that
is equal to one
if we drop the assumption on tau
it can be any conditional independence
then this bound goes to the cardinality
of the set a times the cardinality of
the set b so if each of a and b are
singleton variables this is again one
okay
if sigma is the set of recursive
set of conditional independence is used
to construct the bayesian network then
again we have a boundary of one and we
also prove that this is tight this bound
is basically tied
if sigma is the set of marginal
conditional independences tau is any
conditional independence not necessarily
a marginal one then we again have this
bound of
the cardinality of a times the
cardinality of b and as we showed in the
general case
we cannot make any assumptions we cannot
say that even lambda is a
boundary
and i will mention that this bound of
the cardinality of a times the
cardinality of b is open it might be a
lower
okay so i will i what i will want to do
next i will try to
lower bound
one or
this one would you say that it's open
you mean that
that's just an upper bound but it could
be one
it might be one it might be one it could
be loyal yes
okay so i want to give some intuition on
how we prove these
inequalities uh and so this is what i
will do next i will show a very simple
proof for a very restricted setting
okay and this is what i plan to do next
so for this i will need the following
definition um so
what is an entropic function and the
topic function simply is the following
so we have a probability distribution
and we define a set function
from subsets of variables to the joint
entropy okay so every function that's
given a set of random valves maps them
to the joint entropy is called an
entropic function okay and this is the
notation we call a
alpha is a set of indices
and h of alpha is simply the joint
entropy of the joint random variable
that is defined over this subset of
random variables
um and i will really digress just for a
a second here and say that
characterizing this set of functions is
a major open problem in information
theory
um it is also known in uh result by
matus that there is no finite set of
inequalities that characterize this say
what is called this entomic region so
this is a
this is currently uncharacterized but
this is the definition
okay
so
how what is the technique we used for
the puff so for the puffs we rely on
what is called the i measure theory this
is a theory that was developed by
raymond jung in the early 90s what it
does it establishes a one-to-one
correspondence between shannon's
information measures such entropy and
mutual information and set theory and so
the strategy of the proof is to first
characterize exact implications by
conditions on this measure of entropic
functions and then use this
characterization to prove the
inequalities
okay so in order to really explain the
proof i will have one slide on the ai
major
okay so we have a joint probability
distribution
we associate a set
that we call m of x i with every random
variable and we have the complement set
m c of x i again we and so we have the
joint random variable x alpha and we
denote by m of x alpha the union of the
sets
in
the indices of alpha
f of n is simply the collection of sets
that is obtained by any sequence of set
theoretic operations over this
intersection union complement
the atoms of fn are simply the
intersection of all of the y i's over
all of the random variables so y i is
either the set associated with x i or
its complement
u
which is a function from fn to the ribs
is assigned measure if it is set
additive meaning if a and b are disjoint
then applying mu to the reunion is the
sum
and the mu of the empty set is zero
and the this is a
this is expressed as having that mu of
the atom that intersects only the
complement sets is going to be zero
and finally the i measure is defined as
follows
mu star it is denoted by mu star of the
set associated with
m of x alpha is going to be a the a
joint entropy h of x alpha for every
subset of indices so this is basically
the i measure
okay and the
theorem by young says the following
basically that this new style is the
unique signed measure on fn that is
consistent with all of shannon's
information measures okay what does this
mean so if we have for example here a
set of a three random variables it means
that this
a region if you apply the new star to
this set it's going to be the
conditional entropy
this region is going to be the joint
mutual information this part is going to
be conditional mutual information right
it is the intersection of the sets
associated with x2 x3 and complement of
x1 finally notice this part so this is a
mu star of the intersection of all of
them and this does not correspond to any
a information theoretic measure okay so
it does not necessarily mean that
everything is going to correspond to a
an information theoretic measure and i
will get back to this you will see why
this is important
okay
so we know now in order to provide the
proof intuition i will
restrict myself to talking about only
those probability distributions that
have a positive eye measure this is a
very heavy restriction and but i make it
just to a kind of show the intuition
behind the proof
okay so this is what they
were going to do
and basically why am i doing this
because it is known it was shown that if
a
if we define a uh
we define an eye measure where
everything is always positive basically
we can think about assigning a positive
value to all of the atoms then it is
necessarily we are going to have
something that represents an entropic
function meaning it's going to
correspond to a probability distribution
okay so this is a theorem by you
um i will also say that although this is
a very heavy restriction there are
certain applications that arise in which
these a functions
are relevant especially in the analysis
of constraints in a market basket
analysis which is important
in data mining
if it is positive then it is uh
no it's not a phenomenon if you can have
entropic functions where it is negative
yeah so but this is my just my respect
in order to show it
okay
so
in this case we can almost immediately
say that we have approximate will shut
with a lambda equal to one why is that
so if we have exact implication
then it must be the case that uh the set
associated with tao must be a subset of
the set associated with sigma now why is
that suppose it is not and the figure
here it's a little too light but so so
suppose it is not then i can say okay
i'm going to assign every atom in sigma
the value zero
i'm going to assign some atom in tau to
have a strictly positive value i'm going
to assign it the value one and then
basically we see that
that the
a
that the i measure associated with sigma
is going to be zero the measure
associated with tau is going to be
non-zero and we immediately arrive at a
contradiction of the exact implication
so if we have exact implication we have
to have this
subsumption it must be the case that the
set associated with tau is a subset of
the set associated with sigma and since
everything is positive then we get the
the inequality so we see that the box
that for the set of
this family of probability distributions
we immediately get a
a a one approximation
note in the general case this is not
going to hold in the general case the
fact that the the
that the set associated with tao is a
subset of the set associated with sigma
is not does not necessarily mean that we
have exact implication and they see in
since in the general case not everything
is positive we're also not going to get
the fact that
this necessarily holds but i hope this
gave some idea of how we can use the eye
measure in order to prove these
types of
inequalities
okay
um so
as you as you notice the die measure is
not necessarily going to be positive and
really very simple probability
distributions in which this will not
hold for example for the parity
distribution
x and 1 and the extra independent binary
random variables
we are going to define x3 to be the
parity and if you work out the
information theoretic values you you
will notice that the atom associated
with a
with the
a
intersection of all three sets is going
to be minus one so immediately say that
this powerful note hold in general which
makes it
there
there basically lies the technical
challenge improving these inequalities
and for this uh
for these cases then
the proofs are
in the papers
okay so what i showed you is really for
a restricted setting
okay
so um basically in the time i have left
i will discuss an application of these
ideas of thinking about the
a mutual information in the approximate
sense
um
okay and i will start so here i'm going
to go back to this decomposition of a
relation but i will show how this
relates basically to junction trees
which you are familiar with so here
i showed you before how i can decompose
a relation to two relations but
basically we can decompose a relation
into any number of relations so for
example here i decomposed r into
these four
sub-relations that you see here
they can be organized in this three
okay
and basically uh we
we're going to say that this schema soon
i will say what you've said this this
schema holds in r if when we take the
join of these four relations we're going
to get the original relation back
okay
and this is again defined in a strict
sense i have one i take the join i must
get the original relation precisely as
it is
but now imagine what happens i'm going
to add a single tuple to this relation
which means i need to add a tuple to
this relation bde
but now when i take the join i'm going
to get this very established this tuple
that wasn't there anymore and this is
basically
saying that this schema is now lossy it
does not fit the data anymore and
basically because of this single table
my
schema is going to be invalidated now
okay so it's not going to hold
and basically the goal of this work was
to discover all of the approximate
acyclic schemas that in r and i will
soon define what approximate means but
in a sense we want this
number of stubbles not to be too big
relative to the set of tuples that were
in the original relation
okay and why are these important so uh
in in the database community it is quite
well known that if the query has this
tree-like structure then you have an
efficient algorithm for evaluating
queries over the uh
of evaluating queries
this is the famous algorithm by anna
kakis from 81 more recently it has been
shown that
this
the databases that have this structure
allow for speeding up machine learning
applications over relational data
machine learning algorithms also
work a lot of relational data and if the
relational data is organized in such a
schema then it can be they can be
there's work that shows that
they can be a
the performance is much better
okay so this also you might have noticed
what is so special about these acyclic
schemas they are basically joint trees
right in a cyclic schema we have the
bags they we have the running
intersection property
each one of the edges basically
represents the saturated conditional
independence right so for example here
the edge ad what it means is that these
two sets of the variables given id
become independent
or we can say that this joint dependency
holds
okay so for an acyclic schema i will
denote by ci of s the set of saturated
conditional independences that are
represented in this structure
okay and the
well-known theorem this is again uh you
you you can easily see the equivalent in
graphical models that
the basically in a cyclic schema s is
equivalent to the set of conditional
independencies that are represented on
their edges right basically if each one
of the conditional independencies is
represented by the edges hold then the
entire relation
abides to this rule of the acyclic
schema just like if a probability
distribution
each one of the conditional
independencies represented by a junction
three hold then
the distribution can also be represented
using this junction tree
another thing
uh
that is known is that the number of
these conditional independences is at
most the number of variables in the
distribution right the number of
clusters in a junction tree is at most
the number of variables in the
distribution and hence this number of
conditional independences is also at
most
n
so given this the strategy we can i'm
sorry there was a question
uh so so given this the strategy we can
take is as follows we will discover all
of the saturated conditional
independences that hold in the relation
and then use this to synthesize all the
possible schemes that hold in the
relation
okay so
now fortunately the second bullet here
is more or less a solved problem uh for
this we basically need two things we
first need to be able to characterize
the set of conditional independencies
that can be combined to an acyclic
scheme right we can say there's an
exponential number of of conditional
independences that hold in a
distribution but there's only a linear
number that live together in our
in in a cyclic scheme so unfortunately
this is actually a
this characterization is known it was
studied in the database community it was
studied in the graph theory community
and so this is a we know a how to
characterize these sets of conditional
independences and then we want to be
able to enumerate them and for this we
rely on the previous work of carmeli and
kimmel fund and myself that we showed an
efficient algorithm of enumerating all
of the three decompositions
of a a
basically of a distribution
so basically this second part is a a
second bullet is sort
i will notice that what we are looking
for is these approximate secret schemes
right so not agreeing we don't
necessarily want to be able to relax
this hard constraint that they hold
exactly and
therefore this is going to be the
challenging part
of discovering all the all these
independencies
okay so
in what sense are we talking about
that this is going to be an approximate
so for this let's say consider a little
bit about the information theory of
these cyclic schemes or of junction
trees so here we have an information
theoretic measure that we denote by j it
is simply the sum of entropies
associated with the clusters of the 3d
composition
minus the joint entropy
associated with the edges which is
simply the intersection of the two end
points minus the joint entropy of the
entire set of variables
and
unsurprisingly
in in this same paper by lee in 1987 he
showed and a cyclic schema holds in the
relation if and only if this measure is
zero and i remind you that these
entropies are taken over the empirical
distribution associated with the
relation
um
so so how is this related there to
graphical model so
recall that the distribution associated
with a decomposable model that is a
junction 3 is the product of marginals
associate associated with each one of
the clusters divided by the product of
the marginals associated with each one
of the separators
and what we have shown
is that this j measure
is precisely the scale divergence
between
the a distribution associated with the
as a
joint tree and
a original distribution this empirical
distribution so it is not surprising
that when this is zero
we get precisely what we want we get
this exact uh
that this rule holds exactly
so
in the approximate sense what we will
want to do
right we're going to say we're going to
relax we're going to say okay we are not
going to make this j major precisely
zero we want this gem measure to be some
small value some epsilon we're going to
say this a secret schema approximately
holds if this j measure is at most
epsilon
right we know that if each one of the
conditional independences holds in the
distribution then uh we can say that the
schema holds exactly in r but what about
the approximate case is it's does this
still hold if each one of these
conditional independencies
holds only approximately
what can we say about the
a extent to which the schema holds it
out or that the joint or the distributed
compositions really fits this
distribution okay
so
the answer is yes it is slightly more
subtle though than in the exact case
so what we prove is the following if
each one if for example we put a
threshold on the extent to which these
con this saturated conditional
independence is hold in the a
distribution then we can show that this
j measure is at most linear
it's going to be at most n minus 1 where
n is the number of variables times the
epsilon
okay
so in a sense
we have this positive result that
we can we can combine these epochs in a
strong information theoretic sense we
can combine these a a conditional
independences into this a decomposable
distribution
so
this so this would be the strategy
discover all these
saturated conditional independences that
hold the that almost hold and from those
enumerate all of the cyclic says schemas
all these
decomposable
representations of the distribution
so i will not describe the solution
but the the
the main idea is that there are really
there's an exponential number of these
saturated ci's
however many of them them are redundant
in the sense that many of these
conditional independences can be derived
from others so we don't need to really
uh
in mind all of those that can also be
derived from others so in the paper we
characterize a core set of conditional
independences that is complete in the
sense that any other conditional
independence that holds in the
distribution can be derived from them
using the
semi graph reductions and then we apply
all kinds of spawning techniques
based on these ideas and based on
information theoretic inequalities
so we also implemented this
we also implemented this
a mining algorithm
and as i said basically what uh in the
data management community the interest
is in the error in the sense of the
number of spurious samples that are
generated so what we wanted to see was a
how a does the arrow
which is basically the number of the
percentage of spurious tables generated
when you take the join
how it relates to this savings in
storage or to the extent of the
compression that we get from the fact
that we eliminate a lot of redundancy
when we perform this decomposition
okay so naturally we want to bring that
all down and we want to
increase the savings in storage
and here you see
a
hillway
the algorithm
was able to extract something like more
than 400 the
decomposable models for this
distribution and the nice thing is that
you can see that if you are willing to
incur an error for example of even about
10 percent which is not too much you you
achieve an almost 80 percent savings in
storage so i can you can think about it
in practical sense we can
save these
experience tables
but on the other hand get a very large
savings in storage
okay so i will conclude at this point um
the interesting thing is really to uh to
see how these ideas can really be
applied uh to learning the structure or
specifically learning decomposable
models of probabilistic graphical models
um
so and one difference
one distinction between
that we have a in relational databases
as opposed to distributions is
we assume in the data management sense
that we have the precise description of
the distribution i have this empirical
distribution and this is what i have
okay but in the
general case uh
we assume that we only have samples from
the distribution and then we cannot
really compute the conditional mutual
information exactly we need to we have
these estimates of it and it is not
clear how to
how to define the approximation in this
sense
broadly
what we are looking to do is optimize
over this set of acyclic schemes we are
currently able to quite efficiently
enumerate all of them
uh but
we would like to be able to optimize
over this set a body for example one of
the things we are looking for is if i if
given some
a
some threshold right i'm looking for a
distribution that is at most some
threshold away from the original one i
want to find a cyclic skin that leads to
the loudest compression for example
i will mention here very briefly that
if a
if we assume that the distribution is
strictly positive then we can do much
more
sophisticated things here
one
of the things that also we don't have in
the relational database center is we
cannot assume this positivity that we
saw this a lot in this workshop where
the we assume that uh a joint
distribution is always strictly positive
so we can do other things
this does not hold in the relational
database sense
and the another thing we're looking at
is exploring this connection between the
tail divergence and the number of
spurious stupids you would assume that
this would be monotonic that is uh that
this would be always be monotonic but it
is not the case we can have two schemas
one uh
one the kel divergence is smaller than
the other but it will have more serious
topics so we're looking to really be
able to
answer the question suppose a user says
i'm willing to incur an error of tens
per establish what is the threshold that
i should say so this is also something
that
we're looking at
yes
when i think of database applications i
normally think of like baking or
healthcare where it's like super
important to kind of maybe have all
those records cracked into the database
can you
like correctly in the in the database
can you give some examples of like
applications where you'd be okay with
you know some error in order to have
like compression
so it in cases where i basically in a
in data warehouses will basically for
example use the data to answer queries
or to make predictions so you know in
that in any case your prediction will
not be very accurate uh but
but it can save you a lot of memory a
lot of space a lot of running time if
you have the data in a compressed form
and even if you are willing to incur now
you can think about instead of just
representing the data in a table then
you can represent them in this
decomposed table and also a
and also save the arrow itself and then
when you process the query you take into
account that you have these errors that
you somehow need to
discount their
their effect on the query result so in
any case uh it could be
even for exact applications it can
still be beneficial
yes
super interesting talk so lots of
questions but
just one for now so
um when we do causal discovery then as
you said we do often use methods with
using conditional independence tests all
the time and try to piece together the
underlying algorithm of the underlying
graph from those independence tests
so in that case the independence tests
are often of a parametric form right
that they'll assume god's gravity or
example
so while your results were completely
general right with the
mutual information so what i'm wondering
about is that do you see a
straightforward or easy way to include
these sorts of parametric background
constraints that i might be happy to
make about my distribution into these
results
so
yeah it's a really good question i don't
i don't know in this case i don't have a
good answer
about what
i'm sure we can make it the this
connection between a statistical testing
and the mutual information itself i
at the time i tried to look i did not
find any place that
says
the statistical test gives such and such
a result then the mutual information so
i don't even know what would be the
relation between the two
um but yes you know i just followed then
the other way around is that you know
the example you give was a parity uh
case again and
to me that always seems like okay this
is the degenerate kind of case that we
use to prove certain things are
impossible
but really if that's what i have to
worry about in fact this all the time
then i'm going to be doomed
so
do you have a sense of these sorts of
impossibility results deriving from
really peculiar
distributions or where i'm going to say
parity is a peculiar one so no
so the this is really an extreme case
but basically
you will
these
non-positive eye measures will rise in
any case well if you add additional
variables to your conditioning set you
will not necessarily have a still
conditional independence so even in the
bayesian network structure when you have
your converging then we will have we
will
have this negative there
so this is really an extreme case that i
show for the example but it can
so like if you had a threshold function
um
if
if if we had a threshold you could
reject the sum but we were so it was a
monotone dependence you could still
create this negative yes
so well that's your favorite kind of
collider
if i can assume on my distribution that
each time that i add the
that i add to my conditioning set
uh
i will still i will not get a larger
a
conditional mutual information then i
can immediately say that i will have
this uh
lambda equals one but this is a i think
quite restrictive it does not
instead of putting parametric
assumptions you can add axioms right
like upward stability or composition or
things like that is is there anything
known about what happens when you move
beyond the semi-graphoid axioms for
either the exact the approximate
implication
so if you if you
assume a
if we're some strict positivity of the
probability distribution
um
then we also have the intersection up
term and then basically uh
the algorithm that they showed for
finding these conditional
saturated conditioning dependencies can
be made much more efficiently and
basically it can be translated into a
purely graphical
algorithm
[Music]
the results i showed here in a sense are
they general in the sense that they hold
for polymath they will hope for any
function that is submodular
and monotone
so in that sense it is quite general
if there are specific additional
constraints then maybe
[Music]
maybe we can make this type of algorithm
much more
much more efficient
sort of following up on that in database
applications how important is it to have
this to have these types of implications
for any semi graph
like is it really important to consider
this set of all possible distributions
in database applications so uh you can
as i said
you can't have a you can't assume that
you can have the intersection axiom
because
there's a lot of determinism in the
database applications we have this very
strict uh integrity constraints that are
defined using the first of the logic
sentences so we can't assume that um
maybe there are other assumptions that
i'm not aware of that we can think about
they'll be able to discuss but
there's not something that i'm aware of
oh maybe i misunderstood something but
your sigma is just
independence constraints right so
if i included constraints that bounded
the neutral information between the
variables
um from zero
ensure the certain defenses
between variables then presumably that
would help the kind of
uh
implications that have to reach
about what sort of
other dependencies and dependencies
so
i don't
we don't i don't know of any result
regarding saying that
pair of the values are dependent we only
look at the independence
so
i would guess that if your one of your
sigma is above some threshold
then
this is basically only a lower bound so
i i don't know but again
it's so it's also an interesting
question to say
you're asking about the other direction
you're asking about
an upper bound so the reason i ask is
because when we do constraint based
causal inference we often have
conflicted set of independence
dependence constraints such that there
is no
director basically graph that fits all
of them
because we've had measurement error
along the way and so one of our
independencies or dependencies whereas
and so
then the question is like okay well what
do we do about this sort of about
resolving this sort of conflicted set of
tested experiences
so
one thing that comes to mind is that
what if
instead of learning this bayesian
network or a
a causal model
you go through this
stage where we first
a decomposable model basically we only
learn a junction plate
and then
i think maybe in that sense it can be we
can say i would imagine
this is really like a very interesting
thinking but
say okay if for sunset or random
variables we have we know we have a
strong dependency between them we're
going to force them to be in the same
cluster
and then it basically reduces the
problem to defining the
a directed edges in each cluster on its
own so i i think the way to maybe
utilize these
types of general results is to go
through a
use it to reduce the problem instead of
looking at other values to looking at
the values in each cluster
so thank you very much